dan Patrick show brought to you by the
2018 Mercedes AMG e-class with a suite
of innovative technologies it's one of
the most intelligent cars on the road go
to MBUSA
dot-com or visit your local dealership
to schedule your test drive today
let's bring in Jason Locke and for a CBS
Sports NFL insider and good morning
Jason how are you hope you're having a
quality morning I am and I saw where you
had some information yesterday that you
dropped on us is the kids like to say
with the possibility of other teams
entering in the Odell Beckham jr.
sweepstakes first of all the likelihood
that the Giants would trade him is what
oh I think it's north of 50% I think
it's it's far more likely than not at
this point I mean a player of this
magnitude a player with frankly this ego
a player who's in a position who knows
that in a 32 team League there are
numerous teams who would be comfortable
paying him far more than Sammy Watkins
got I mean say Watkins got a legit 34
full we guaranteed over two years so
that 20 million a year on a short-term
deal it's out there Frodo and if the
Giants don't want to pay it because of
the baggage and the video and and the
owner now sort of you know ruminating
publicly about his desire to have this
guy on his roster that's fine but the
money's there so if it takes him pulling
a Dwayne brown and sitting out half a
season and then coming back in time to
get a zackrude season or forcing the
Giants hand in the meantime on a trade
you know the Schirmer and gentlemen
really want to spend the first eight
weeks of the season being asked every
single day about the best player on the
team who's holding out I don't think so
and the Giants know this so they've got
a you know a decision just pay the man
which they don't seem inclined to do or
train them before the draft when you can
get present-day assets that you know
will help your football team because
heaven knows they need help
I do think he'll be dealt but you're
looking at a couple of first-round draft
picks is you is that the asking price I
don't think they're gonna get it III
don't I I don't because of what I just
said
the teams will give you you know full
value for a player if there's a bargain
or a potential bargain on the contract
but if I'm taking this problem child off
your hands and as good as he is and
still only 25 you don't think he's worth
market value then I'm not going to give
you full value for the player and do
that okay so I think it ends up being a
1 and a 3 maybe a warning it too
maybe just a 1 and a player I don't know
that they'd get to first-round picks for
MA I just don't because of the the
various scenarios had this going down at
the combine Dan before guys like Sammy
Watkins got 34 million fully guaranteed
before the Jacksonville Jaguars decided
that Donte Moncrief and Mark Easley are
worth 30 million guaranteed combined you
know before people started paying guards
like elite left tackles then then I
think it's a more robust market and and
teams hadn't burned through their
budgets yet so so maybe it's more likely
that you get a full value football trade
for them I just don't see it happening
as we creep closer to the dress what do
you make of the Gronk situation and sort
of the I don't know cryptic messages
that he sent climbing across head in
your climate Impala Jack's head and
you're playing Ziggy freud with either
of those guys Godspeed I'm not really
going down that rabbit hole Rob
Gronkowski has been a bargain since he's
been since he came back from the last
major back surgery and yeah he had
another knee injury since then but then
he bounced back from that and was once
again the most dominant tight end in the
game so if you want Rob Gronkowski to
keep playing football for you you need
to compensate him in line with his
production if you don't then he can sit
there and you know he can chew the curd
about the WWE or you know doing B movies
with John Claude Van Damme or whatever
awaits him out there on the other side
of the rainbow but I think the Patriots
understand what the reality here is from
a financial standpoint and they've got
some things to sort through with
politics long term future or midterm
future and you know Tom Brady's a
bargain too and
got some other holes to fill but I don't
I'm not I'm not buying that there's this
mind war going on between Paulo check
and Gronk I think both guys understand
what it's going to take for him to get
back on the football field and at some
point through the course of a six to
seven month offseason those
conversations will occur and I think the
Patriots will put more money in
Gronkowski's pocket and he'll ply for
another couple of years and then we'll
say we got Jim Mora and he's gonna join
us in about 15 minutes is he helping or
hurting Josh Rosen with his comments
depends how you look at it I'm gonna
kind of take the up it's a contrarian
view but maybe an outside-the-box you I
think he's kind of helping him because I
think he knows this young man really
well and I think he wants what's best
for this young man and I don't know that
that Josh Rosen and Hugh Jackson would
be a good coupling I don't know that
that would go so well and frankly any
quarterback that goes in Cleveland as
much as I value what John Dorsey is
doing there I think you have to worry
about am I going to purgatory like even
if we win six games next year are they
sticking with you Jackson is the guy
long term to get them over the hump but
if they're not is there going to be
another offensive change and another new
scheme and relearning things and you
know somebody else's playbook and that's
obviously not ideal and Cleveland's been
a place where quarterbacks go to die I
mean that's just been the reality and
and if you're Jim Moore and I can't put
words in his mouth and I'm sure you'll
get you know you'll ask him I guess in
15 minutes about it but my read on it is
boy I don't know
can I go with summer with a clean slate
with the Giants that sounds pretty good
and and even the Jets where they haven't
had a good quarterback there and forever
and if this kid comes in and is even you
know stable and okay in year two and
looks the part then people are gonna
rally behind him or am I going to
Cleveland where I just saw what they you
know what that staff just did with
Kaiser and I know Todd Haley's there now
as a different offensive coordinator but
let's face it you know he was an
offensive guy and you know even Kessler
I mean it's just been it's been a
minefield for young quarterbacks
and I think in his own way maybe that's
the point coach Moore is making
where do we stand with Aaron Rodgers
getting a new contract oh that's an
inevitability that's that's going to
have to happen it's just going to be a
matter of that at what price point if
you're Aaron Rodgers you're not in a
hurry
you've seen the the Falcons sort of
flint and winced a little bit about the
price tag for Matt Ryan I mean if you're
Aaron Rodgers you really don't know
worried about a contract until week one
of the NFL season is you know has Matt
Ryan pushed you know how far over 30
does he push or you know where does his
where does his number come down Aaron
Rodgers is the best quarterback in
football and and he obviously still has
time on his side in a way that some of
these other guys like a Drew Brees and a
Tom Brady just don't so is it 30 to 5 is
it 33 year I don't know but but that's
where this is heading and there's really
no way around it and I think the Packers
fully understand that good to visit with
you Jason
help talk to you soon thank you that's
Jason locking forum it's a twitter
handle is at Jason lock and for CBS
Sports NFL insider for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]